La volta al món a peu, dia 262
Sempre gossos, tu
Cada nit gossos
Després no es veuen, eh?
Però estan, perquè borden
Bueno
A part d'això, una bona nit
Són les 6 i 37
Avui em desperto relativament d'hora
Continuem caminant
per Tajikistan
Atenció que passa un tractor
just pel davant
Crec que no m'haurà vist
però si no m'hagués amagat tant
si m'hagués posat al costat d'allà al camp i ja està
m'hauria vist segur
Encara m'hauria saludat i m'hauria donat d'esmorzar
coneixent aquesta gent
Jo intentant esquivar el de la màquina
i ha aparegut aquest home d'aquí al darrere
amb el carretó
que quan m'ha vist sortir del
camp aquest de pomers
m'ha mirat amb una cara
com si estigués fent un fantasma
i em va dir
què fa una persona aquí
i li he fet el gest de camping, dormir
ok
mai t'ha sigut
ok, me'n vaig a l'alma
i tot bé
t'heus dit
si no
no hi ha cap problema
doncs són les 9 del matí
i he caminat 11 quilòmetres i mig
està molt bé
ahir a aquesta hora encara no m'havia ni llevat del llit
molt bé
doncs ara tocaria parar
en aquest poble
en teoria hi ha alguna cosa per parar
menjar alguna cosa que no sigui
galetes, beure alguna cosa, refrescar-me
és a dir que a les 9 ja
el sol directe durant dues hores ja
tinc el cos bastant
escalfat
i ja comença a apretar
aigua amb gas per hidratar-me
cafè per a veure si evacuo
i pollastre per alimentar-me
són les 9 del matí
què, potser és massa això per esmorzar
potser, potser sí
potser sí
em venia de gust
a veure, què tal la situació de la panxa
doncs home, entre poc i massa
ara fa més de 24 hores que no
no vaig de ventre
i tampoc penso que tinc molta gana
això vol dir que estic bé
que ja m'ha curat
o és que tinc un tap allà posat
jo espero que després d'aquest cafè
m'entrin ganes
i llavors ja us diré què tal ha anat
un altre cop m'han convidat
molt bèstia, molt bèstia
el cafè, l'aigua, el pollastre
que estava bo
estava ben cuit
estava ben rostit
tenia la sal correcta
estava bo aquest pollastre
i no m'ha deixat pagar res el tio
li he quedat simpàtic
m'ha ensenyat fotos d'un viatge que hi va fer
a Londres
i ja està, no he pagat
bueno, tema ventre, no?
doncs sí, he anat, he anat
i ja no surt líquid
no és líquid
ara és
tampoc diria que és sòlid 100%
però bé, ara diria que bé
o sigui que
estic satisfet, estic correcte
anirem monitoritzant
no us diré res a partir d'ara
si no us dic res, que estic bé
en pitjora ja us tornaré a explicar
però si no, diria que ja m'he curat
següent parada
el següent poble
que no sé si està a 10 o 5 km
hi ha una botiga de megafon
que és la botiga, la companyia de mòbils
de la meva targeta SIM
m'acaba d'arribar un SMS que diu
que si no passo per una botiga de megafon
en els propers 5 dies
em desactivaran el compte
perquè es veu que tenia com 5 dies
15 dies de
de període de gràcia
no ho entenc molt bé
el motiu, si jo vaig contractar per 30 dies
doncs em passaré per allà
i a veure què em diuen
com va
la 1 i 26
23 km força bé
he pagat una bona estona a una manginera
que estava molt fresca
i ara anem a megafon
crec que està aquí
si no és aquí, és aquí a prop
A veure si em soluciona això, perquè no pot ser que em quedi sense internet.
Ha costat una mica entendre'ns, perquè no parla l'anglès,
tota l'estona amb el traductor de Google,
però sí, m'ha demanat el visat, li he donat el permís GBAO,
perquè el visat no, no tinc un paper que no sigui el visat,
tinc el permís del PAMIR.
Però bueno, ja l'ha sigut suficient,
i crec que ho ha fet, que m'ha desactivat això de...
Mira com, mira la pavimentació.
M'ha desactivat el tema aquest que s'anul·larà a les 5 d'aquí 5 dies i ja està.
I a més a més, hi ha una cosa que passa aquí, a Tajikistán,
que passa també a Turquia,
que és que tu no pots importar un telèfon d'estranger
sense pagar impostos i posar-lo en un e-sim i ja està.
Et donen 30 dies pels turistes, però si ets un local no val,
perquè has de pagar.
Bueno, sí que pots, però has de pagar les taxes d'importació.
Llavors és molt louco perquè t'arriba un SMS
que et diu el teu Samsung S24 amb el teu e-mail tal,
d'aquí 30 dies es bloquejarà,
si no pagues les taxes, que no són petites.
És depèn del valor del mòbil.
I són, poden ser cent i pico euros, o dos cents,
depèn del valor del mòbil.
A Turquia això passava, el que passa és que no és després d'un mes,
sinó era després de tres mesos,
i els impostos són brutals.
De fet, els turcs fan broma,
i quan han de comprar un mòbil, o importar-lo, o el que sigui,
el que diuen és la meitat per mi i la meitat per Erdogan.
I els mòbils de Turquia són megacards per culpa d'aquest impost.
Bueno, hello.
Llavors, quina és la trampeta?
Clar, jo tinc dos mòbils.
Jo tinc dos mòbils, llavors, el que havia pensat jo era,
doncs, compro un e-sim, no cal ara, sinó d'aquí una setmana o dos,
a un altre de megafon, de per l'altre mòbil,
llavors, bueno.
Tinc internet a l'altre mòbil, però, bueno, sempre puc compartir, no?
Però, bueno, aquest noi d'aquí m'ha dit que tu pots fer el truc de tenir dues sims
en el mateix mòbil.
M'estranya, perquè, en teoria, si et bloqueja l'e-mail de l'S24, del mòbil,
t'hauria de bloquejar per totes les companyies.
Però, bueno, no ho sé.
Doncs, bueno, compraré la sim per l'altre mòbil i el trobarem aquest, i si no, doncs, tal.
Tampoc estaré molt més de 30 dies totals a aquest país, jo crec,
jo crec que en 40 ja estaré fora.
I els últims 10 dies crec que l'internet serà tan escàs que ni podré pujar els vídeos.
Això és clar el que m'han dit la Noa i l'Òscar.
Però, bueno, ja ho veurem.
Ara mateix, un a 45, segueixo caminant.
Hi ha un incendi aquí, al costat d'una benzinera, tu.
Bueno, són 4 amatois, eh, però la gent passa tan tranquil·la, tu.
Bueno, sembla que ara ja s'està apagant.
Sí, sembla que no s'ha hagut res.
Buah, quina calor que fa.
Quin, oh, és que només la ombra ja, està la ombra, oh.
És brutal, eh, uf.
Vaig a comprar aigua.
Són les 4 i 36, porto 35 quilòmetres, que està molt bé, és el mínim que m'estic plantejant cada dia.
Gairebé 800 metres de snei positiu.
I em trobo bé, estic fort, no tinc cap problema a la panxa i enlloc.
Ja estic motivat, mira, canvi de paisatge, ara una mica de muntanya, totalment sec, però també guapo.
No sé si sóc jo o què, però ha baixat una mica la calor.
Estic motivat, vinga, som-hi, endavant.
42,4 quilòmetres, una marató ja, són les 6 i 22.
I he trobat un lloc de campada de l'aplicació eOverlander, que us he parlat diverses vegades.
Està a 4 quilòmetres i pico.
Cosa que vol dir que arribaré més tard de les 7.
Sempre a les 7 m'agrada, repeixo campar, perquè a les 7 i mitja se'n va el sol, llavors tinc més temps.
Però aquest lloc té pinta de molar, per tant, intentaré arribar.
Ei, mira que m'he pillat.
Seblon Kebab.
És un kebab sense carn.
És un lloc que fan pa, aquí.
I feien això.
I dius, ostres, fos amb un.
I he donat una mossegada, està bastant bo.
Faig una salseta, també, tomàquet, cogombre, com sempre, pastanaga i el pa.
Molt bé, tu, força sa.
Encara passaré per algun altre supermercat per comprar aigua i esmorzar,
doncs ja ho tindríem.
Doncs el lloc que deia l'aplicació era allà.
Trobo que està molt bé, trobo que és molt encertat.
Aquí tenim el caminet que ens hi portarà, som-hi.
Els últims quilòmetres que faig abans d'arribar al lloc de campada,
que vaig carregat amb 2-3 litres d'aigua extra, les cames ho noten, eh?
Bueno, el lloc està molt bé, tu.
S'ha de buscar el lloc pla, perquè no tot arreu és pla, però sí.
Sí, sí, sí, no hi ha massa pols, que és el problema d'aquest país,
que hi ha molta pols, aquí hi ha com arbeta tallada.
Bon lloc, bon lloc. A més, bones vistes, això sí.
I demà a primera hora em menjo el sol a sac.
Però molt bé, tu, content. A campo.
Estic cansat, eh?
47 quilòmetres i 1.000 de desnivell positiu.
Déu n'hi doret.
Dos refrescos, he parlat amb dues persones de converses,
encara que a saludar he saludat moltíssima gent.
Cap cafè, crec que... No, sí, un cafè avui.
Anava a dir... Ho deixaria de dir, però no, no, és que avui he pres un cafè.
Novetat. I de diners, res, de diners.
M'he gastat 6 euros, sí, sí, i encara gràcies.
Molts han sigut aigües, que anava comprant durant el dia aigües.
Bueno, ostres, estic baldat, eh? Però molt satisfet.
De fet, avui 47 quilòmetres.
Molt bé, tu, molt bé.
Aquest lloc té punxes, punxes de plantes que estan seques i punxen.
Ja he mirat que sota el matalàs no hi hagués.
Compte amb això.
I... i també m'han vingut 4 gossos.
No han vingut fins aquí, però sento que comencen a bordar.
Sento que comença, es comença a aixecar pols allà a lo lluny.
I, bueno, s'han posat a 50 metres i han girat cua.
Eren 4 gossos bordant, eh?
I venien corrents.
No sé si és que m'han vist i han tingut por o algú els ha cridat.
Sento vaques. No ho sé.
Home, 4 gossos aquí defensant els ramats mai haurien pogut destrossar, eh?
Jo crec que aquest país és bastant més tranquil en aquest tema.
Sí, bueno, com a mínim ara ho està sent.
Bueno, ja estem a un altre entorn.
No us he ensenyat gaire aquesta tarda, però això és bastant diferent de la part plana de Duxamba, eh?
I fa menys calor, sí.
De fet, ara em passaré una aigua per sobre, però fa una mica de ventet i sé que agafaré un pèl de fred, eh?
Tampoc ens flipem.
Ara mateix, doncs, deuen fer 24 graus o així, però...
però molt millor que la calorada que feia ahir i aquest matí.
Fins demà.